We said buffer overflows are bad,
so, what can we do beyond just
relying on the programmers or coders
to avoid those kind of vulnerabilities?
One way we can do that is, remember that
one of the tricks that hacker uses is to
override the return address field that
we have on the stack, in a stack frame.
Whatever the function you were executing
when the bad input has to received,
the return address is modified.
That should not be during
the execution of that function.
There is no reason for
that return address to be modified
because this return address is
where we are supposed to go back.
And where we go back should not change
while we're executing this call
function.
Okay, so how can you detect if
the return address has been modified?
And if it's been modified
there is an overflow and
if you can automatically detect that
then you can stop things right there,
program can terminate or
something like that.
So how can we detect any modifications?
So one technique is what
is called stack canaries.
So these are sort of like coal mines.
We have those birds that tell you when
the harmful gas concentration is high or
something like that.
What we can do is just before
the return address in a frame
we can store when
the function call is made.
At that time we can store a canary
value in a location that is
just before the return address.
If you're going to overflow
into the return address,
you're going to come
wire this canary value.
So if the return address
gets overwritten,
chances are that the canary value
is going to get overwritten also.
So all you had to do is,
before you return from the function, you
check if the canary value has changed.
You knew what the canary value is
when the function call was made
because that you had placed it in this
location just before the return address.
So you're going to what
that location contains now
with the value that you knew.
If they don't match then
there is an overflow and
potentially the return
address has been modified.
And if it's been modified,
then you shouldn't go on.
We have detected a buffer overflow and
that potentially could
change program control flow and
lead to attacker code and so on.
So that modification should
basically indicate to us that
there is a problem here.
So a canary value basically just says,
if it had changed this is
done automatically isn't it?
The programmer has to do nothing.
We compile it the way
sets up the stack and
sets up the data structure
within the stack frame.
That's where we add in this and
we checking it automatically.
So the programmer has to do nothing
to get this extra security that comes
from this defense that we just talked
about that detects buffer overflows.
So stack canary is one
way that you can do that.